what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and many of you might have heard that
Marvel Studios is seemingly canceling
their appearance for Hall h at San Diego
Comic-Con this year however I am not 100
convinced that this is entirely true
it's probably true however I still
believe there is a chance that Marvel
Studios will be attending San Diego
Comic-Con this year and will be doing
their Hall age panel but at the same
time Marvel Studios is making some
pretty big changes to not only the
Multiverse Saga but how they're doing
things internally as well plus not to
mention the rider strike that is
happening right now there's a lot of
things affecting not only Marvel Studios
but the movie and television industry in
general however with this supposed
cancellation of Marvel Studios attending
Hull H A lot of people are talking about
Warner Brothers and DC Studios having a
massive Presence at San Diego Comic-Con
this year so clearly even with
everything going on it is still very
possible for Marvel Studios to attend
but we'll break down everything that you
need to know in this video and if you
want to stay up to date on Marvel and DC
be sure to subscribe to the channel and
if you leave a comment you're entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X a PlayStation 5 Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month all you got to do
to enter subscribe and leave a comment
so this report of Marvel Studios not
attending San Diego comic-con's Hall h
this year is coming from the wrap I'll
just read what they wrote on their
article online because it is a super
quick read they state after making a big
splash at Comic-Con in 2022 Marvel
Studios will Skip Hall h this year the
rap has exclusively learned now right
away what's kind of interesting about
this is they don't really say how they
learn this they don't say they spoke to
somebody at Marvel they don't say they
have a source at Marvel that told them
this so we don't know what their source
is on this Marvel Studios did not
officially tell them exclusively that
they are skipping out on San Diego
Comic-Con this year or else they would
have stated that so right away that
gives me just a tiny bit of hope that
Marvel Studios could still be attending
but the rap is a pretty big outlet and
they do have sources that do give them
some Insider information so we'll assume
that it is canceled for now but even
reading more into this article there is
still a little bit more hope it
continues to State Marvel will however
have a presence on the convention floor
the studio which has always given
convention goers flashy first looks at
upcoming movies and shows currently has
multiple Productions on pause due to the
ongoing Rider strike the Productions
currently on pause include blade
Thunderbolts Daredevil and wonder man
they continue to State the writers
strike along with a potential strike by
sag
a-f-t-r-a is making it tough for Studios
to show up to the annual convention
without product and performers to
promote their projects if the SAG aftra
is unable to reach a deal on new labor
contract and orders a strike actors
would not be able to do any promotional
work for their films and TV shows as
part of the labor stoppage sag a-f-t-r-a
could order a strike anytime after their
current contract with Hollywood Studios
expires on June 30th if a deal is not
reached San Diego Comic-Con is set to
take place on the weekend of July 21st
now a lot definitely is happening like I
mentioned in the movie and TV industry
and yes if this new strike happens then
it will be pretty hard to have a big
Presence at San Diego Comic-Con because
your actors can't show up which
definitely puts a damper on things and
if Marvel Studios is pulling out Apollo
H this year it is probably because there
are so many variables the rider strike
the SAG strike the reshuffling of their
Phase 5 and Phase 6 schedule their
production for movies and shows being on
hold right now there's a lot of
variables that could keep them away and
Marvel Studios could have simply gone
you know what there's too much that is
unsure right now we are unsure if the
strike is going to happen so as of right
now let's tentatively say that we're not
going to show up however if the
sag-a-f-t-r-a which stands for the
Screen Actors Guild American Federation
of television and radio artists does
reach a new deal and doesn't go on
strike Marvel Studios could always
decide hey we are going to attend
college because that would mean their
actors could show up typically Marvel
Studios does talk about their latest
upcoming movies and shows and they have
the actors from the movies and shows
appear on stage and talk a little bit
about the upcoming movies and shows
however a huge part always of Marvel's
Hall h panel is the reveal of new
projects future upcoming projects and we
all know that Kevin feige could
definitely do this by himself now at the
same time Kevin feige is a team player
he loves his Marvel family and seemingly
always tries to do what is right so
although we could have a Hall h panel
with just Kevin feige talking about all
of these upcoming movies and shows and
revealing the entirety of phase six he
probably wouldn't want to do that
although it is a possibility now there's
also the concern that the Fantastic
forecast might not be locked down yet
and based off of what some insiders have
said this was supposed to be a pretty
big reveal at San Diego Comic-Con which
is what we are all expecting as well and
really looking forward to and the latest
update with that is Marvel Studios is
kind of having trouble with the budget
for the cast specifically the main cast
who is going to be playing Mr Fantastic
The Invisible Woman the Human Torch and
the thing now the rumored cast that was
supposedly pretty locked down was Adam
Driver as Reed Richards Margot Robbie a
sue storm Paul muscal as Johnny Storm
and David Diggs as Ben Grimm now Adam
Driver and Margot Robbie are definitely
going to be looking for a big Heyday
there and from what we heard basically
the cast for these four members right
here was going to be around 80 million
dollars which is a huge sum of money so
this is is apparently where they've run
into a problem and based off of what
we've heard the cast is not officially
locked down yet but we know that Kevin
feige did want to announce it at sdcc so
this is probably just another one of
those things contributing to their
decision to skip out on it plus not to
mention last week it was revealed that
Marvel Studios did some rearranging and
rescheduling of their Phase 5 and Phase
6 slate the release date for the Marvel
stayed the same and Deadpool 3 actually
got moved up but other projects got
pushed back including Avengers the King
Dynasty which got pushed back an entire
year in the same four Avengers Secret
Wars it got pushed back a year as well
so there are a lot of factors affecting
Marvel Studios decision to skip out on
San Diego Comic-Con however if somehow
all of these pieces do end up lining up
the rider strike possibly ends the SAG
strike does not happen in the Fantastic
forecast gets finalized then there is
always the chance that they could decide
to attend and of course San Diego
Comic-Con would absolutely love to have
the Marvel studios's Hall age panel is
typically the event it's one of the
biggest events of sdcc each year people
literally line up for it a day before
they camp overnight in line just to get
a seat for Hall h i will say that I did
reach out to my Disney contacts they did
not have any comment for it on whether
or not Marvel Studios will be attending
I do have hope that they will be
attending however we are going to act
like they are not pronounced that way if
they don't we won't be disappointed or
shocked so for now we assume Marvel
Studios is not going to attend there are
many reasons for this that we've talked
about in this video and hopefully since
they're not attending hopefully when
everything gets cleared up Marvel
Studios will do some type of event on
their own they've done this before
during the pandemic it's virtual so
everybody can tune into it hopefully
that is what happens fingers crossed on
that because we definitely need an
update from Marvel Studios and of course
if we hear anything else on this subject
matter we'll be sure to update on you so
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
note notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos also
don't forget to leave a comment so you
can enter the giveaway we're also on
patreon now if you want to support the
channel we have a website and we have a
Discord server as well and you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf wolf
me
baby